المهاجرون من دول غرب افريقيا تقطعت بهم
السبل هنا في مدينه فانتيميليا على الحدود
الفرنسيه الايطاليه وما زاد من معاناتهم
انهم وقعوا ضحايا ازمه دبلوماسيه اندلعت
بين روما وباريس على خلفيه ملف الهجره
والمهاجرين غير النظاميين هنا يبدا
المهاجرون يومهم يغتسلون ويستحمون بمياه
النهر البارده وعلى ضفتيه اقاموا عالما
موازيا بعيدا عن مجتمع معاد لهم وينظر
اليهم بازدراء احيانا
قاعدين تحت الكوبري ونغسل من مي البارده
دي
وما في اكل زي الناس وبطاطين ما في ما في
فرشه زي الناس
معاناه بعض المهاجرين هنا مركبه فمن بينهم
تشاديون مثل ناصر الذي ولد في السودان
واقام فيه لكنه تركه بعد الازمه التي
اندلعت واصبح غير قادر على العوده ما نقدر
نرجع السودان مشاكل قبليه ومشاكل سياسيه
كل شيء هنا منذ فتره اسبوعين وما نقدر
نروح فرنسا يرجعوك من القطار اعداد
المهاجرين في ايطاليا اليوم هي اربعه
اضعاف ما كانت عليه السنه الماضيه بحسب
الحكومه وضع سيدفع روما الى خوض مفاوضات
خلال الاسابيع المقبله مع القاده
السياسيين في تونس وليبيا و خلالها ستقترح
ايطاليا مساعدات اقتصاديه ولوجستيه على
البلدين مقابل تشديد مكافحتهما للهجره من
سواحلهما
لكن الى ذلك الحين لن تخلو سكه القطار هذه
من المهاجرين فصعوبه التضاريس الجبليه بين
ايطاليا وفرنسا جعلت احلام هؤلاء معلقه
بقطارات تعبر الى الجانب الفرنسي على امل
ان يبطئ احدها فيتسللون اليه وتكتب لهم
حياه جديده في فرنسا من مدينه فانتيميليا
الايطاليه فادي الدهوك العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات